relief for nick amelia and his
supporters
after three months of incarceration the
leader of georgia's largest opposition
party
the united national movement walked free
from pre-trial detention in rustavi
prison
and was engulfed by the media he said
his release
was a victory for democracy in this
country
the part of the population
realized that either we have the
oligarchy regime
or we have the democratic rule
concerned that melia's arrest appeared
politically motivated
european diplomats played a key role in
negotiating his freedom
nicomelia's release has been made
possible thanks to the european union
which posted his bail money worth almost
twelve thousand dollars
but it's only been the latest in a
string of interventions by the european
union
to try to resolve georgia's
long-standing political crisis
melia was arrested in february in a
dramatic raid on his party offices
wanted in connection with his role in
anti-government protests
that turned violent two years ago
his arrest exacerbated a political
stalemate in georgia
the opposition had been refusing to
enter parliament
claiming fraudulent elections last
october
but weeks of talks mediated by the
european council
ended with a deal last month the
government has promised electoral and
judicial reforms
in exchange for opposition politicians
returning to parliament
most opposition parties have signed the
agreement
but not the united national movement do
you think it's time now for your party
to
go back into parliament personally yes i
think
that we have to continue our activities
and the political
process in the parliament from the
parliament in the street protest so i
mean
you know it's like the political process
that could mean the end
finally of georgia's political deadlock
within the walking distance to overcome
this crisis
walking distance to your car at least
walking distance to your
it freedom must now decide whether it's
time for his party to take its place
again
in georgian democracy robin forestia
walker
al jazeera rustavi